[Music]
oh there we go
Kardashian explains why she's been
wearing a bandage on her face revealing
she recently underwent a procedure to
have a tumor removed on Tuesday the
reality star detailed The Experience on
Instagram saying that it all started a
few months ago when she noticed a bump
on her face assuming it was something as
minor as a zit Khloe had the bump
biopsied after two dermatologists deemed
the bump incredibly rare for someone her
age that's when Coco says she was told
she needed an immediate operation to
have the tumor removed and thankfully
now she's in the healing process as for
that bandage Chloe says it might be
around for a while so she plans on
rocking it in fabulous style
but once it's removed the good American
founder says she'll most likely have a
scar on her cheek but she's feeling
grateful for the medical team that took
care of her and Chloe's reason for
sharing to remind everyone to make those
regular visits to the doc I am only
sharing this story with you so I can
remind everyone to get checked and
frequently I think for every sister we
have different boundary levels and we
all try to respect that what is in the
media is sort of things that we feel we
need to film because it's in a way
unfair to the viewers if they don't get
to see that we've shared so much about
our lives especially the older ones
we've been doing this for so long we'll
just have to wait and see if Chloe's
Health scare plays out on the Family's
Hulu series The Kardashians tune in
because you never know what's going to
happen but Chloe's Mama jar Kris Jenner
revealed a health scare of her own after
having pain in her hips cameras
documented the emotional experience
makes me want to cry
no it makes me want to cry like because
it scares the [ __ ] out of me it's just
like you don't want to feel like you're
going to be that person on a walker I
can't tell my kids I'm scared they have
enough problems they don't need to worry
about Mom